les couleurs de l'italie sur la façade
de l'hôtel de ville de rome pour
redonner de l'espoir
la pandémie a tué 627 personnes en 24
heures c'est un record
la lombardie est la région la plus
touchée autour de milan sa capitale les
hôpitaux sont débordés les autorités
sanitaires italiennes ne savent pas
encore quand cela va s'arrêter
non ça brime on my queen aux annales
picot si nous ne saurons jamais
exactement quand le pic sera atteint
nous pouvons raisonnablement parler sur
la base des restrictions actuelles
concernant la semaine où les deux
prochaines semaines mais nous n'avons
pas de données scientifiques à ce sujet
il n'y a que des tendances et des
évaluations qui devront trouver un
retour au petit fût money qui payent des
entraves à risque ont jeté de nouvelles
mesures de confinement plus strictes
sont donc mis en place tous les parcs
espaces verts et jardins publics seront
fermés au public dès ce week end
objectif inciter les italiens à rester
chez eux au maximum les hôpitaux sont
engorgés mais les morgues le sont aussi
chaque jour le virus fait des centaines
de victimes pompes funèbres et
crématorium ont du mal à faire face aux
médias même s'il veut faire briller
en ce moment nous recevons en moyenne 25
cercueil par jour mais nous ne pouvons
gérer que 12 évidemment cette situation
crée un engorgement anormal nous allons
à une phase d'urgence et nous obligeant
à nous arrêter pendant quelques jours
afin de pouvoir récupérer de l'espace
c'est le même problème que bergame av et
c'est précisément pour cette raison que
nous recevons les cercueils de touques
italie centrale et du nord
ils n'ont plus d espace dans les
stockages provisoire de cercueils dès
lundi des mesures de confinement plus
drastique encore seront prises en italie
et si la célèbre scala de milan ferme
ses portes
pour certains le confinement prend des
airs d'opéra